with its tech empires of you're
struggling Japan has been forced to turn
to a new wave of rebels and
unconventional thinkers for fresh ideas
and no one exemplifies this better than
Toshi Yuki Anoka and his company team
lap ver inoko inspiration struck when he
was just 8 years old
he's any good at the game in my second
year of junior high I usually tell
people that an electric wave struck not
sure what it actually was or even how to
describe this but a strong sense of duty
that I needed to do something that had
meaning in society suddenly came over me
if that red pill is still circulating
through your system then this will feel
perfect a sibling to go find a fish it's
one of team labs world-famous
techno art experiences
they use this projection mapping
technology to track the fish when they
hit somebody's body I supposed to turn
into a flower
all right we're supposed to move on
how long does it take to do one of these
projects not forever
we take one idea and create reconsider
then repeat the process for example the
exhibit you saw crystal universe is that
we've been working on for five years the
pool one we've been working on for two
to three years team lab has around 400
employees thinking up new ever weirder
things and working in their makeshift
laboratories what's this one
very not got good spin again you're
making clothes right I think it's for a
show it's for a dancer no he's making
clothes for a mascot
here we're experimenting with a device
that allows you to manipulate waves in
the water you're gonna make patterns in
the water
and control the pattern yeah that's cool
Kanako is known throughout Japan as a
flamboyant character for him you either
create something new or you grow old and
stay quiet la you know is that I love
Japanese society has aged too much it is
a society of old people it's
conservative and it can't seek value in
new things so you're trying to change
that no no no no no no I want to be with
people who want to take a step into the
new world
people who are creative we want to
change the world these people I hope to
inspire and to have an influence on or
by having them experience our art I want
to shake their values so rather than
taking on people who don't want change I
work to inspire people who want to
change